no protective shoes
we'll go floor like all the others
[Music]
I had a dream it was the end of the
world
is that the Age of Heroes would never
come again pastel fun engaging those who
do this together
each of us in some way is held back this
is crazy
Wyatt brought you together
I serve the world and I did the man was
a piece tip that's the world he didn't
have save people see the best part
[Music]
fighting the devil his army and help
here we go three two one
hey guys thought I might crash your
little watch party
I have a question that is the mother of
all our questions
when will you release this minor cut
it's a hard question I don't know what
do you think I mean I reckon you should
show we're doing it so ready
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Justice League teaser
trailer for the Snider cut you probably
saw HBO dropped an official teaser
trailer yesterday there's some deleted
scenes during that a whole lot of black
suits Superman we also have some details
about Henry cobbles possible return for
a Man of Steel sequel that I'll talk
about during the video too and a clip
from Ben Affleck talking about what's
going on behind the scenes so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what you want them to add back in to
Zack Snyder's cut of Justice League the
way he tells it he actually says that
we've only seen about 25% of the movie
that he intended to make when he had to
leave the project you have to keep in
mind that he's talking about doing it is
a six-part maxi series I'll explain that
too because that was ex nighters idea to
break it into six different parts tell
it more like you would read The Watchmen
comic book which obviously is a big
Easter Egg for his Watchmen movie but as
you see during this we get a whole bunch
more of Henry Cavill in the black suit
as Superman it's unclear exactly what
else they're going to be adding back
into Justice League beyond the stuff
that I talked about yesterday there's a
whole bunch of deleted storylines
subplots character moments Zack Snyder
said that mostly it's a lot a lot more
character development but just yesterday
after they announced the news and
everyone was going crazy Ben Affleck
actually dropped this clip thanking all
of the fans
so here's him talking about it I just
want to say I'm sorry I couldn't make it
on their live but I'm very excited
exacts getting a chance to finally see
his vision realized I think it's a great
thing I'm really excited for the fans to
get to see it and I want to say thank
you to the fans because it was their
enthusiasm and their passion that made
it happen without fan support I don't
think every what happened and I love
Zack and I love his version of movie and
I look for
to everyone getting chance to see it
what up Smith even if you haven't seen
all of Kevin Smith's movies or you
haven't watched them in a while you
probably remember the Affleck phantoms
reference that's from Jay and Silent Bob
Affleck was the bomb and phantoms yo it
is funny to hear him make that reference
himself as opposed to someone like Jason
Mewes or even Kevin Smith but thanks to
Zack Snyder and the people that were
talking about what was going on
yesterday we found out about the
circumstances behind the Snyder cut in
how it came to be but it was last year
in November 2019 that Warner Brothers
officially went to Zack Snyder and asked
him if he was interested in coming back
to do this Justice League Snyder cut or
they're calling it Zack Snyder's Justice
League technically what they're going to
be doing is giving him between twenty
thirty million dollars they're
estimating to do some reshoots and do a
bunch of special effects rescore the
film with a different soundtrack
probably bringing back junkie XL because
that was the person he originally wanted
to do the soundtrack obviously Zack
Snyder said yes I will come back and do
that because he dropped this clip the
other day and they dropped this teaser
for it but Snyder himself said that he's
working with the cast to try and get
them to all come back for reshoots
however many reshoots he needs I think
that's mostly just a bridge scenes
because when he was forced to leave the
project it was really just the bones of
a movie it was barely a movie there was
a lot of green screen there's a lot of
unfinished special-effects there's a lot
of stuff that needs to be done it's not
something that they could just drop
online right now and we could all watch
and the really cool thing about Ben
Affleck coming back as Batman for at
least a little bit for some minor
reshoots is that originally it was Ben
Affleck who reached out to Zack Snyder
to tell him about the Snyder cut
movement and what was going on with the
fandom so it sounds like he's willing to
come back schedule pending obviously the
virus has delayed everything and
everyone's schedules are all over the
place so who knows what they're gonna be
able to pull off but because all the
cast members were using their social
media accounts to officially offer their
support to the Snyder cut it sounds like
they're all willing to come back that
includes Wonder Woman Henry Cavill
Superman obviously there was a big
question about what was going on with
him till he showed up on that Man of
Steel livestream oh by the way I think
you should show it to bringing back the
flash Jason Momoa as Aquaman he actually
dropped a separate clip yesterday saying
that he wasn't sure whether or not they
were actually going to drop it
may have been lying and know that they
were actually going to do it but I can't
play the audio from his clip in this
video just because it's so hardcore I
don't want the video to get flagged
needless to say he's really excited for
people to watch that cut of the movie
and as you saw during that snider cut
teaser trailer they had the post-credits
scene with Deathstroke Joe Manganiello
was on Twitter yesterday saying that
there's a whole other version or a
deleted scene of that post-credit scene
with him so apparently there's a bunch
of Deathstroke that we didn't get to see
that they'll add back in for the Snider
cut Zack Snyder was posting more screen
caps from deleted scenes this is Ryan
Choi at STAR Labs he's obviously the
second version of the atom so I don't
know if he's gonna get a suit during the
movie or if he's just gonna be a big
easter egg for the atom but on my video
yesterday a lot of you were asking
questions about what they were gonna do
about the green lantern that got cut out
of the movie who would be playing him a
lot of people were joking that really
should bring back Ryan Reynolds is Green
Lantern for the Snyder cut obviously
that's not going to happen
Ryan Reynolds probably doesn't want to
go anywhere near Green Lantern unless
it's to make fun of himself as Green
Lantern
you're welcome Canada for those of you
asking though it does sound like they're
gonna be using special effects to put
Darkseid back in the movie although it's
unclear how much Darkseid is going to be
in the movie and separately a lot of
people were asking yesterday if they're
doing this for the Justice League the
Snyder cut will they do the same thing
for Suicide Squad because there's a
whole of the cut of that movie and a
bunch of deleted storylines that he was
forced to get rid of by the studio they
came in and put all those pop songs in
and we wound up with what we got in
theaters the official AT&T Twitter
account commented on it making it sound
like yeah don't hold your breath on this
happening anytime soon and David Ayer's
tweets himself also kind of supported
that like yeah wish this could possibly
happen but probably not gonna happen
there were also some of you on my video
yesterday asking if the Snyder cut is
going to be canon to the DC EU and if
it's successful if they're gonna do more
down this route I don't think that
that's going to happen I think it's just
a one time deal and it's gonna be
something for the fans to enjoy and
that's about it like they have Matt
Reeves and Robert Pattinson Batman movie
coming next year they're still gonna be
making a trilogy of movies with them
they still have their plans for the
Wonder Woman franchise Wonder Woman 1984
and Wonder Woman 3 they have the
like Adam movie all the other movies
they're developing the whole idea of the
Snyder cut is they're just letting Zack
Snyder finish what his original vision
was because he was forced to leave
because of a tragic family circumstance
so just treat it like a one-off thing
but on the more positive side of
changing things going forward it does
sound like Henry Cavill is trying to
lock down a deal with Warner Brothers to
return for another Man of Steel movie
whether there's a straight-up Man of
Steel 2 sequel movie or they take it in
a slightly different direction remains
to be seen
just him coming back for a really big
Superman movie which I think everybody
wants to see give him one more chance to
do a really awesome version of Superman
and then we'll just see what happens
after that if he wants to continue or
they want to do a third Man of Steel
movie of some kind that's still wide
open to Theory crafting it sounds like
there's still a lot of work to be done
behind the scenes a lot of actors were
in the middle of renegotiating their
contracts even grant gustin's said that
he was in the middle of renegotiating
his contract to continue playing the
flash on TV but because of the virus
they had to stop that so he's not sure
whether or not he's coming back for
season 8 or season 9 at the flash yet
but let me know in the comments if they
really do turn this into a six-part six
hour event week to week what do you want
them to include during it and what do
you want to see going forward what kind
of Man of Steel sequel do you want them
to do every one click here to learn
about all the deleted storylines and
subplots that they're bringing back for
the Justice League Snyder cut and click
here for my brand new Mandalorian season
2 teaser trailer with Boba Fett thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]